hey this is really interesting
um conspiracy theorist alex jones
appears not only to have completely
turned on donald trump at this point but
seems to be lining up behind ron
desantis now little bits and pieces of
this we've picked up over the last
couple of months there was a story from
a couple of months ago where over
vaccines
uh alex jones seemed to have turned on
donald trump
recently
i believe during an interview with
marjorie taylor green
alex jones said something about a
desantis green presidential ticket
but now alex jones straight up is saying
desantis is better than trump let's take
a listen to this this was from a recent
episode of
infowars
i've gone from liking to santa's to
loving to santas to my instincts have
told me he's good and now he's he's he's
he's got my full backing wow he's the
real deal he's uh better than trump
i'm not trying to pick favorites here i
want trump to get jealous and become
more like desantis we all need to be
more like desantis he's a gentleman he's
smart he's a family man he's a patriot
he's a veteran he is our leader
i mean have you got about who's leading
the fight against the new world order
it's tucker carlson and it's desantis
this is a major i mean for alex jones to
declare someone else his leader i know
it's very easy to laugh all of this
stuff up and go alex jones who's a
it is actually it's it's horrifying
but it actually matt there is a movement
here and when they declare a leader it
actually matters for classy men that are
gentlemen that really care about
everybody that i would say are the best
examples of leadership in america it's
desantis and tucker carlson i'm
obviously the shock trooper that you
know is the is the kraken you release uh
and and i'm proud to be that but i can
tell you that that my job has been to
expose this and bring in the men and
bring in the women uh i i use kind of a
john the baptist analogy god told me
that god's like
alex jones is john the baptist now i
mean look at how sick this is but but
again
if they are getting behind the santas it
actually does matter you are going to
launch the attack you are going to
prepare the ground your people are going
to prepare the ground and then you watch
the leaders will rise uh and and we're
seeing that and all of us are rising
ladies and gentlemen but i just give
credit where it's due it's people like
desantis and and people like to carlson
i've almost got rogan super hardcore
he's almost there
i don't know if that's true by the way
that he almost says rogan maybe it is
maybe it isn't or and then he kind of
goes back a little uh but uh
i just got to spend more time with him i
love joe we can hang anytime i want him
to call him yeah let's go get dinner i
gotta hang out sometimes we hang like
twice a week i just you know it's just
joe is really such a sweetheart that the
that but he doesn't want to be in the
middle of the fight not because he's a
coward he's almost embarrassed to be
that deep in the fight and it's just
okay so
alex jones here making it clear that
desantis is their leader interestingly
enough when you look at the money line
when you because you
you one of the great things about
america great or terrible you can bet on
anything you want and people bet on who
is the republican nominee going to be
and it has not shifted significantly if
you go to predict.org you can look at
the betting markets on a lot of these
different questions and the question who
will win the 2024 republican nomination
it's pretty steady
but desantis is very close to trump
trump about 38 cents of every dollar is
being bet on trump will be the nominee
and 29 cents of every dollar is being
bet on ron desantis is going to be the
nominee so this is let's put it this way
this margin for trump right now in terms
of who people believe will be the
nominee for the republicans in 2024
this is one scandal away from reversing
if
trump has some major scandal that's
really embarrassing among the
republicans and of course his his most
devoted followers don't care but if it's
something that
people who are still slightly connected
to reality are are turned off by
that nine point that you know that's a
four and a half point swing right in the
sense that if trump loses four and a
half and desantis gains four and a half
you've got a tie for the republican
nomination
those are precarious numbers for donald
trump given that we are two and a half
roughly
years out from the 2024 election so it's
a race to the bottom believe me but it's
a race to the bottom that we care about
because the consequences are
unimaginably huge huge as i talked about
earlier republicans winning elections in
the next two election cycles
imperils american democracy
and so that's why we care
whether alex jones is abandoning trump
or not and he does indeed seem to be let
me know your thoughts let me know your
thoughts about who you believe will be
the republican nominee if it's something
you're already thinking about you can
find me on twitter at deepakman it is
april 1st and it is great to be here and
we've got a packed program for you
coming up today it is a brand new year
maybe you have goals around getting in
better shape maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman